socialized health care isn't it about
time that we get on board
people have been praising that system
for years in these countries like say
canada for instance
they live three years longer than we do
and that's in part because they have a
universal health care system
but if you don't pass universal health
care by july of 2009
in six months i'm going to use my power
as president
to take your health care away from you
canada has a single-payer system
the good thing about single-payer is the
administrative costs are quite low
clearly the united states needs to join
the rest of the industrialized world
with a real national health care program
it is underwritten by the government
it's free for everyone you never have to
worry about it costing anything
so i decided to put it to the test
no really i i went to canada
oh canada the land of strong beer funny
accents the slightly larger cadbury egg
and free drugs at least that's how the
american media would tell it
heck even our own president wants to
move us in that direction as president
i will sign a universal health care plan
into law
by the end of my first term in office
which is why i've decided
to go through the socialized canadian
health care system with a couple of my
favorite canadians to show you exactly
what it's really like
hey i'll live with you for a week what
no no that's tim my longtime best friend
and a born and raised canadian
he likes long walks on the beach and
wu-tang clang
he brings the ruckus to the ladies
oh my god and that's
john my other best friend he just
happens to have a canadian medicare card
as well as a lot of free time in his
hands so he was perfect for the job
now it's important to know that this was
all done gorilla style
unlike other filmmakers armed with full
crews and scripts we wanted to get true
authentic reactions and show you folks
what it's really like to get treatment
in a socialized healthcare system so the
audio and video
might be a bit raw but you're probably
watching this for free anyway
so shut up all right first things first
we wanted to head down to the local
clinic and see what kind of treatment
we'd get there
but it was the weekend and as people in
the emergency room later told us
um so i guess the clinic is closed uh on
sundays or
weekends weekends it says uh
i guess we have to go to the hospital
tim uh time
okay so it's 106 and uh we're going to
the hospital now
come back let's see what that's like
come on
um i don't know how long it'll be this
is what what'd you call this triage
the triangle
excuse me can you tell us approximately
how long the weight is
until finally we got to see the nurses
all the sure yeah you're relatively in
i'm partnering with a lot of uh
waiting today so which days are usually
the shortest or the longest days for
weights here
so no gloves
now once you see the nurse of course you
have to wait again for a doctor
and as a lady at the front desk had told
us that could take a while
it's been an hour and a half so far we
just saw the nurse
and uh they're about to send us to well
now we're just another waiting room
waiting for the doctor
and uh they can't give us an idea how
long the weight is gonna be between two
and ten hours so
now we wait we'll keep you posted
so we waited
and waited
until honestly i realized that uh pj tv
doesn't pay me enough
all right so we just left the hospital
we've been waiting for uh
say at least four hours and a guy with a
broken clavicle
uh who was in there it took him five
hours for a turnaround
to finally get his care and uh they
finally couldn't do anything they just
told him to go see
an orthopedic tomorrow and uh there was
another guy in there who was waiting
nine hours for penicillin so considering
that tim had a
uh what we thought might be a broken
wrist he wasn't such a high priority and
we were not gonna wait around for nine
hours today
but uh
we'll give the clinic a shot tomorrow
granted emergency rooms can always be
really tough to deal with but what if a
canadian wanted to get something simple
done like a blood test
well it just so turns out that john
wanted to do just that he wanted to test
his cholesterol levels but doesn't have
a family doctor
we went to the local clinic to find out
what he needed to do
just in line here for the clinic waiting
to
get into the parking lot
and of course more long waiting ensued
but uh this time we came prepared
oh man screwed up backwards
pansies high spot with my little eye
something that is
red i spy with my little eye something
that
is sexy
oh i found it
is this real life until finally
we were able to see the nurse at least
this time she was friendly
uh i was looking to get a blood test no
i don't do it here i can't get a blood
test here if you're sick maybe we can
see if
we need that but no
to get a foreign yeah can i test the
clsc
okay and he doesn't have a family doctor
okay because if we
ask the blood test here the doctor that
chris creek blood test
need to make um a three piece
acquisition
yes
you need to be your passion okay right
but it's hard to get a family doctor
the only thing that you can do is just
call in the
um from the number i did
and just ask how the clinic if they have
family doctor and give your name to the
list that they have
i did that like three months ago yes and
maybe it's like two
three years three years to get a doctor
you're young so you have the time you
normally don't that they don't have
problems at uh
they suggested i get a family doctor but
that's what i was calling for and yeah
now you need to wait so or you go in
that clinic
okay is there one near here yes that's
right that's we have to pay
yes it's 900 costs for your
you have a health checkup okay okay and
with that uh
900 yes wait did she just recommend
what i think she did but paying for
better health care
what if i went right now to a clsc and i
couldn't just wait sure
no i'm not sure because the data that
they have there it's
they have the patient that they need so
they don't want any more patients
you can try but i don't i don't and you
you live where
greenfield park even park yeah so where
do you see let's see
there's one in st lambert okay yeah you
can try but i'm not sure
okay okay well you heard her we didn't
want to wait two to three years to see a
family doctor
so we decided to take our chances at the
clsc who knows
maybe some canadians get lucky right
okay to see a doctor here
is
okay yeah it's always monday to friday
oh
skunked again looks like we'd have to
wait another day
so we managed to fit it in within their
ridiculous hours
only to be told so you you didn't have
any documentation three years ago a long
gay
kanji actually said you were none why
uh the government
no doctors what they don't pay it's not
enough money here no but if you have
cash someday you can you will have a
doctor
this way some days if you have cash
that's it oh well i appreciate your
honesty because we went to the clinic
and i waited and i saw the doctor there
and she said
please doctor here okay or see a family
doctor
go there come here do that but there's a
private clinic would you like to pay
wait hold up a government employee
recommending a private clinic
so believe it or not after all of this
um the lady upstairs as you just saw
referred us to a private clinic she
seems to think that would be a little
more efficient than
the canadian government but as we said
that goes against the rules by which
we're playing right now we want to
experience the kind of healthcare that
canadian canadians pay for with their
tax dollars
um so quest continues you know maybe we
were just the odd ones out i've got a
face with a lot of punch appeal so
maybe people might not be likely to give
me the best treatment so we decided to
check with other fellow canadians to see
the kind
i was at work and we were ripping down
some stuff doing some demolition
and i stepped on a board that had a
rusty nail
and i went to the clinic and i waited
and waited
and then when i saw a doctor they said
they ran out of tetanus shots in the
comeback thursday
i didn't go back what day was it when
you actually went in
that was monday did they know that you
had stepped on a rusty nail
uh yeah i told them i stepped on a rusty
nail
and i guess that didn't matter uh maybe
i should have
sat on it or something to get their
attention i don't know what i could have
done
i have no idea you mentioned that hayden
was was pretty sick and you take her to
the hospital
um what was wrong with her what did they
do about that she
had a gastro and normally it lasts 12
hours for babies but for her it was
going on
two or three days we were getting
worried she wasn't she was very
lifeless and lethargic so we took her to
a hospital and we ended up waiting
seven hours before they saw her and when
they saw her they just said she has a
gastro and they send us home
but when we took her home her fever got
really bad and we were getting scared
for her so we took her to the children's
hospital
where there we waited two hours just to
see a nurse and they ended up keeping us
for almost a week so at the other
hospital they just generalized her
they didn't actually look into her
symptoms and see that she was really
sick they just sent
us home that's what happens a lot
okay so um but two hours actually that's
really good even for for baby emergency
that was just to see the nurse though
and then we had to wait after to see a
doctor
so i'm sure because they see a lot of
children with gastro that they didn't
actually
listen to that she was sick for more
than
the normal time for a baby to be sick so
yeah
it happens a lot with a lot of people
you have to see sometimes a specialist a
dermatologist um what's that like
well basically you would wait anywhere
from five to seven months
and it takes maybe
a maximum of three or four minutes to
get diagnosed and
get your prescription and if that
doesn't work which in my case i just
went to
clear up my skin and it didn't work so
i have to go get something else but it
takes so long that i just
it's kind of discouraging to make an
appointment so i just end up not making
one at all
i would have to make one right away as
soon as i saw that it wasn't working but
sometimes you don't know if it's working
or not until later on so
it could take a good good year and a
half to to actually get the right kind
of medicine for
for what what you're needing and there
are millions of other stories like these
out there
consider that the average wait time to
see a specialist in canada is 17.3 weeks
and that is of 2008 over 2.8 percent of
the country's population are in waiting
lists to receive special treatment
and there are bound to be a few unhappy
campers the truth is that these horror
stories are so
common because the canadian healthcare
system is overburdened and because of
its inefficiency
is underfunded to keep health care
spending to a minimum
they have to ration it but at least it's
free
right well not really when you take into
account the average
income tax that someone in quebec canada
would have to pay do these numbers look
ridiculous
they should the truth is that a huge
amount of tax is required to keep this
system
afloat because like all government
programs it's proven to be
terribly inefficient even claude
castongay the man who
headed the government commission in
quebec that led to creating this system
has declared it a crisis and has
acknowledged the need to eliminate the
government monopoly on health care
through allowing more privatization so
while we're heading their way
canada is starting to head hours oh i
almost forgot uh the sales tax in quebec
is always over twelve percent and uh
actually over fifteen percent of some of
the other provinces
actually it's worse than that let me
show you how it works
see in canada there's a federal gst
which right now has been thankfully
reduced to five percent then each
province adds their own provincial tax
like the quebec qst
which is a little under eight percent
here the problem is that the provincial
tax
is only added on top of the goods or
services after the five percent gst has
been totaled
so you're essentially taxed on tax
taxed on paying taxes
really well you know i guess it's not
really fair to just look at numbers and
statistics
because as everybody knows socialism
creates a safety net that allows for
poor people to have a higher quality of
living in
all other areas of life right
how much is the sub in the states five
foot long see you know the jingle i
thought it was six
so what would the theme slime be here
8.99 foot plus tax
high tax actually going back to canada i
noticed that everything
even before taxes was far more expensive
just compare the subway sandwich shop
receipt
to what you'd pay in the united states
the truth is that everything seemed more
expensive in canada
it wasn't uncommon to find things with a
30 40 or even 50 percent higher price
tag than in the united states
at least gas is cheap
yeah when i left it was uh i don't know
in california it was close to three
dollars a gallon
it's what meters it's liters
okay so the average price of gasoline in
the usa at the time of this filming was
just shy of 264.
fitting 3.79 liters into a gallon would
average the canadian gas price somewhere
around
383. all right all right the day was
getting long and
all this math is getting boring cause
math is for suckers folks so we decided
to take the rest of the day off and
celebrate
how do you feel about canada sir fine
this canada is
beautiful
i think you said it's a beautiful
country and something about a planter
swartz
you got the horses going go
canada what's good times
all right so now we know about the
socialized health care system and i know
what you're asking
well what would be wrong with having
both socialized and privatized at the
same time
well the problem with that is that you
end up creating a two-tiered system
where the only people who can get decent
health care are the super
rich now you remember what the nurse the
clinic told us
900 costs for your you have a
health check-up and with all of the
income tax and ridiculous sales tax and
expensive cost of living
the poor and middle class in quebec
don't have that kind of money to burn
the rich will always be able to afford
the privatized
better health care whereas the average
canadian is going to have to continue to
wade to an ever deteriorating system
that they pay for whether they want to
or not if they want privatized health
care that would be comparable to an
american having to pay for two separate
private insurance plans
see when you remove choice from the
equation it's
always the middle class who gets piped
so do you still think that obama is
moving us in the right direction here
be sure to let me know what you think
below now on the other hand if you're
actually concerned about the state of
socialization that's coming our way
be sure to pass this along and take an
active role by writing letters to your
congressmen and women
oh and by the way we never were able to
actually get that blood test
we ended up just doing it at home